SPEAKER 1: Welcome to
Google Cloud Drawing
Board, where we doodle
our way through the Cloud.
Today's topic-- What is
Google Kubernetes Engine?
This video is divided
into chapters.
Watch the full
video or skip ahead
to any section of your choice.
Now, Sam, the system admin,
calls Aaron, the developer.
Her application has crashed.
But it worked just fine
on her workstation.
They check the logs, debug
stuff, and eventually
version inconsistencies.
The right dependencies were
missing in production--
no surprise there.
Together, they perform
a risky rollback,
will later install the
missing dependencies,
and hope nothing else breaks.
Aaron and Sam decide to
fix the root problem once
and for all using containers.
Containers decouple the OS from
the application dependencies
in the code.
Due to this abstraction, Sam
can log into each machine
and instruct it to run
Aaron's containers.
It will pull down
just the files that
have changed since the last
container and run the new code.
If you need to roll
back, all the old files
are still there, as container
images are immutable.
By using containers,
Aaron and Sam
solved the "it worked
on my machine" problem.
Containers help improve
portability, credibility,
deployment speed,
reusabillity, and more.
Turns out Sam's responsible
for more developers than just
Aaron.
With large number of developers
containerizing their apps,
Sam needs a better way to
orchestrate all the containers
that these developers
are shipping.
Solution?
Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is a portable,
extensible open source
platform for managing
containerized workloads
and services.
But turns out,
Kubernetes is not that
simple to manage, from
installation, to provisioning,
to upgrades, SLAs, and scaling.
So Sam looks into Google
Kubernetes Engine.
GKE is a managed service
for running Kubernetes.
Apart from making it easy
for you to create clusters,
it offers some advanced
cluster management features,
including load balancing,
auto scaling, auto upgrades,
auto repairs, logging,
monitoring, and more.
Now, how does GKE work?
All Kubernetes objects
in your containerized app
run on top of a cluster, which
is the foundation of GKE.
Cluster consists of at least one
control plane and one or more
machines called nodes, which
are created during the cluster
creation process.
The control plane includes
the Kubernetes API server,
scheduler, storage, and
core resource controllers.
The control bay is responsible
for deciding what runs
on all the cluster's nodes.
This can include scheduling
workloads, managing networks,
storage, lifecycle,
scaling, and upgrades.
Now, the nodes-- a
node runs the services
necessary to support the
containers that make up
your clusters workloads.
These include the container
runtime and the Kubernetes node
agent, Kublet, which
communicates with the control
plane and is responsible for
starting and running containers
as scheduled on that node.
Pods are the smallest, most
basic deployable objects
in Kubernetes, and contain
one or more Containers.
Pods also contain shared
networking and storage
resources for their containers.
Now, how do you GKE?
We know that GKE works
with containerized apps.
So before you deploy a
workload on GKE cluster,
you must first package
it into a container.
To create a
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery pipeline,
you can use Cloud Code
to write your apps,
send the code to a
source code repository,
which kicks off a build
process in Cloud Build,
leading to container
images, which can then
be stored in Container
Registry, ready to be
deployed into [INAUDIBLE].
You can then create
the GKE cluster
using Cloud Console UI,
G Cloud Command Line
interface, or the API.
Kubectl CLI comes
pre-installed in Cloud Shell
to run commands against
your Kubernetes clusters.
High availability and scaling--
for availability, you can choose
between two types of clusters,
zonal and regional.
Regional clusters are
better suited for HA
because they have
multiple control planes
across multiple
zones in a region,
while zonal clusters have one
control plane in a single zone.
This also means that
changes to cluster config
takes longer in a
regional cluster
because they must propagate
across all control planes.
Due to these trade-offs,
choose regional clusters
when availability is more
important than flexibility,
and use zonal cluster to create
or upgrade clusters rapidly
when availability is
less of a concern.
GKE also provides four types
of autoscaling for workloads
and infrastructure-- horizontal
pod autoscaler for adding
and removing pods based on
utilization metrics like CPU
and memory; vertical
pod autoscaler
for sizing your pods;
cluster autoscaler
for adding and
removing nodes based
on the scheduled workload;
node auto-provisioning
for dynamically
creating new node
boards with nodes that match
the needs of your users' pods.
How to secure your
app using GKE--
GKE is secure by default,
with automatic data encryption
at rest and in transit.
The OS images you deploy
are Google certified.
You can access your
clusters without public IP
on the internet.
And you can control access using
identity and access management
and role-based access controls.
Additionally, with GKE,
you get trusted networking.
Using global VPC,
you can connect to
and isolate clusters.
Using global load balancing,
you can deploy public services
behind a single
global Anycast IP.
Using Cloud Armor, you get
easy protection against Layer 7
and DDoS attacks.
And using networking
policies, you
can control the communication
between your cluster pods.
GKE also comes with tools
to verify, and enforce,
and improve the security
of your infrastructure.
You get binary
authorization to ensure
only properly signed containers
are deployed to production.
Vulnerability scanning
of the container images
find security vulnerabilities
early on in the CI/CD pipeline.
And since the base
images are managed,
they are automatically
patched and updated
for security vulnerabilities.
With all that said, if you are
looking to quickly start with
containers, check out
GKE at cloud.google.com
/kubernetesengine.